todesschüsse vor backshop mord im suv
blutfehde nach streit um sitzplatz im
kino 28 schüsse von shisha bar aus üblen
beleidigung wird üble schießerei all
diese taten spielen in einem einzigen
berliner bezirk im wedding in den
vergangenen monaten gab es hier
unzählige gewalttaten die hemmungslos in
aller öffentlichkeit ausgetragen wurden
von massenschlägereien bis mord unsere
reporterin delhi von der osten berichtet
aus berlins blutigsten bezirk
bereits inter januar 19 uhr polizei
sirenen heulen blaulicht flackert durch
die nacht in berlin wedding ein passant
entdeckte den blutüberströmten körper
von abdul jalil b auf dem fahrersitz
seines geparkten autos kurz zuvor schoss
ein unbekannter auf den 47 jährigen
familienvater eine kugel trifft abdul
die liebe am kopf der passant alarmierte
rettungskräfte doch für den fünffachen
vater kommt jede hilfe zu spät abdul
jaleel b stirbt wenige stunden später im
krankenhaus
aufgrund der auffindesituation die durch
die schutz verletzungen auf ein
tötungsdelikt hin deuten ließen hat
unsere achte mordkommission des
landeskriminalamtes die ermittlungen zu
diesem tötungsdelikt übernommen die
ermittler stellen an update leds auto
keine einschusslöcher fest der killer
muss also bereits auf offener straße auf
den 47 jährigen geschossen haben
lebensgefährlich verletzt muss abdul
jaleel sich dann noch in sein auto
geschleppt haben blutspuren an der fuß
kante des wagens markieren sein wie ein
grausamer mord auf offener straße doch
ein fall wie dieser ist hier im berliner
problembezirk werden kein einzelfall
fast täglich kommt es hier zu brutalen
straftaten die in vielen fällen sogar
tödlich enden
über 150.000 einwohner leben in den
ortsteilen gesundbrunnen und wedding die
bis vor einiger zeit einen gemeinsamen
bezirk bildeten das ehemalige
west-berliner arbeiterviertel ist
wohnort für ur-berliner und migranten
und immer wieder tatort für mord
totschlag und brutale fälle von
selbstjustiz zum vergleich im jahr 2020
werden in wedding 13 1890 straftaten pro
100000 einwohner verübt doppelt so viele
wie im bundesweiten durchschnitt dabei
stehen fälle wie schwere
körperverletzung und raubüberfälle auf
der wettringer tagesordnung in diesen
fällen rückt die polizei im
problembezirk mehr als viermal so häufig
an blick auf die tötungsdelikte die fürs
gesamte letzte jahr in wedding mit 8 mit
einer zeit von 8 zu beziffern ist und im
gesundbrunnen sprechen wir von drei
vollendeten tötungsdelikten der mord an
update gb ist der letzte fall einer
blutigen serie von straftaten allein im
letzten halben jahr zwanzigster juni 23
uhr eine shisha bar in der müllerstraße
zwei maskierte männer schießen in dieser
lauen sommernacht gezielt auf gäste der
bar nach bild-informationen peitschen
insgesamt 28 schüsse durch die weniger
nacht drei männer werden schwer verletzt
kommen ins krankenhaus die täter
flüchten es heute fahndet die polizei
nach ihnen die spur geht ins kleine
milieu
einen monat später und keine zwei
kilometer weiter der 46-jährige htm b
sitzt an seinem stammplatz in einem
weddinger backshop am nettelbeck platz
friedlich trinkt tee bis sich ein mann
er seine waffe zieht und auf den 46
jährigen familienvater feuer tmb bricht
schwer verletzt zusammen die
rettungskräfte können nichts mehr für
den mann tun er stirbt noch am tatort es
war rache ats sohn soll drei monate
vorher den sohn seines killers in einem
park in gesundbrunnen erstochen haben
wir fahren nach wertingen und wollen
wissen wie es den bewohnern des
problembezirks geht sie klagen über die
hohe kriminalität schon lange fühlen
sich die einwohner nicht mehr sicher wie
fühlen sie sich in berlin mögen sie den
ring den wenig also in letzter zeit
nicht mehr er war es schön dass so viel
verdrückt hier zu viel
macht sicherheit richtig jeden tag immer
was passiert alles verändert sich das
bunt zu 20 jahre 25 jahre war auch ganz
normal jetzt schlimmer ihre stimmen
gewonnen eine police da kommt eine g ist
wichtig gegen die kriminalität im
gegensatz zu früher ist ihr jetzt ist
gestiegen
angefangen hat hat wenn die anderen
ausländischen geschäfte gehen deutsche
geschaffen auf dem die frau schwan
beweisen sie
anfang oktober 23 uhr eine straße weiter
ein seit jahren andauernder
familienkrieg zwei roma familien findet
hier sein blutiges ende mitten auf dem
gehweg liegt ein 42 jähriger in einer
riesigen blutlache wenig später stirbt
er ein zweiter oktober erschienen
hameter hier vor der shisha bar hier
wurde er hingerichtet wie im kinofilm
hingerichtet mit zwei kopfschüssen
eiskalt und brutal kurz vor dem
grausamen mord sitzt samir uhr in einer
shisha bar beim pokern bis er den
42-jährigen hamid es auf der straße
entdeckt da miro läuft nach draußen
kehrt kurz darauf mit seiner waffe
zurück und schießt damit h von hinten in
den kopf
um sicherzugehen dass hamit wirklich tot
ist schießt er dem 42 jährigen aus
nächster nähe noch ein zweites mal in
den kopf eine hinrichtung im wedding auf
offener straße der bordstein ist kaum
von hamid als blut gesäubert da fallen
schon die nächsten tödlichen schüsse im
wedding am morgen des 23
novembers wird der 39-jährige mahmud f
in seiner wohnung im hinterhaus
erschossen sein killer betritt um sieben
uhr morgens mahmud efs wohnzimmer
schießt ihm in den kopf und flieht vom
täter fehlt auch zwei monate später jede
spur
allerdings brutale bilanz sieben
quadratkilometer vier tote und
mindestens drei schwerverletzte in nur
sieben monaten
abdul jalil b ist tot erschossen im
alter von 47 jahren seien killer
flüchtet unerkannt vom tatort auch das
motiv und der genaue tathergang sind
noch völlig unklar die polizei ermittelt
unter hochdruck doch es ist nur eine von
vielen bluttaten in berlin wedding
ja und über berlins blutigsten bezirk
wollen wir weiter sprechen mit unseren
experten mit professoren sandra schmidt
die bei uns ist und professor christian
matz darauf guten abend herr mart stores
sie waren selbst viele jahre kripo
ermittler im wedding nehmen sie uns
einmal mit zurück in diese zeit gibt es
einen einsatz der der bis heute bei
ihnen hängen geblieben ist ja ich habe
auch in den 90er jahren schon in berlin
gearbeitet werden war immer etwas
besonderes das war immer etwas brutaler
es gab die jugendgruppengewalt und der
einsatz der mich am meisten
beeinträchtigt hat jetzt aus der
heutigen sicht ist der fall eines jungen
mannes der in einer öffentlichen
toilette im schillerpark dort fast
totgeschlagen worden ist mit schwersten
verletzungen schwerbehindert überlebt
hat und ich hatte die aufgabe sowohl den
fall an dem fall zu ermitteln als auch
den eltern bescheid zu geben die auf der
einen seite nicht nur die schlimme
nachricht von dem unglück hier mitnehmen
mussten sondern eben auch erfahren
mussten dass ihre jugend offensichtlich
ein doppelleben geführt hat und sie eben
gar nicht kannten das war sehr schwer
das hat mich lange zeit sehr beschäftigt
frau schmidt jetzt ist es so in berlin
ich muss das ablesen ist der abschnitt
17 der polizeidirektion nord für den
wedding zuständig wie muss man sich das
vorstellen sind dort die beamten
besonders gut ausgerüstet gibt es
besonders viele beamte dort oder muss
dort die leitung in wahrheit mit genauso
viel polizisten wie in jeder anderen
polizeidienststelle sonst auch der
ausstattung personelle ausstattung
sachliche ausstattung der dienststellen
richtet sich schon danach wie groß die
einsatzbelastung sind und welche einsatz
und qualitäts phänomene dort zu
bearbeiten sind viel wichtiger darauf
möchte ich hinweisen sind die
unterschiede auch in bezug der oder in
bezug auf die zusammenarbeit der
kollegen kollegen also mitarbeitender
auf solchen brennpunkt dienststellen
entwickelt einen sehr starken
zusammenhalt sie fühlen eine gefahren
gemeinschaft sie arbeiten schulter an
schulter sind hochmotiviert es entsteht
eine hohe identifizierung mit der
dienststelle mit den kollegen und mit
dem kiez und dabei ist das arbeiten dort
sehr belastend und sehr gefährlich also
weil der druck von außen so groß ist
rutscht man selbst in den reihen
rhythmen in der ein enger zusammen ja
das kann man so sagen kann was ihrer
erfahrung wie reagieren denn menschen
tatverdächtige zeugen auf die polizei im
wedding redet man und spricht man damit
der polizei oder wird eben das meiste
mittlerweile intern und untereinander
geklärt ich habe schon den eindruck dass
es ein gewisses grundvertrauen gibt
gegenüber der polizei aber man schweigt
häufig aus angst aus dem eigenen umfeld
was zu werden also das gilt sowohl wie
für jugendliche straftäter wie oft
menschen aus dem kriminellen milieu man
hat angst vor dem eigenen umfeld vor
rache möglicherweise vor dem druck der
dort steht es gibt allerdings auch
einheiten die einen ganz besonders
standing haben also ich denke an die
operativen gruppe jugendgewalt auch im
wertigen diese einheiten haben dabei
soll es formulieren die kennen ihre
schweine umgang sozusagen die haben das
tatsächlich eine wie man
umgangssprachlich sagt ein standing bei
den leuten und da spricht man auch
anders mit ihren also auf augenhöhe
und da sind dann auch manchmal die ganz
harten jungs plötzlich ganz artig und
antworten wenn sie gefragt werden so wie
es gehört spielt sprache sie haben es
angesprochen also einmal jugendsprache
aber der wedding ist multikulturell wir
wissen das spielt das auch noch rolle
also setzt man da vielleicht auch
verstärkt auf beamte mit
migrationshintergrund hilft so was wenn
man aus der eigenen community kommt es
gibt ein eigenes arbeitsgebiet gerade
für diese kombination interkulturelle
kombination und natürlich haben wir
zahlreiche mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter
die
sprachkompetenz haben und auch
kulturelle kompetenz und die ist einfach
nötig um den link zu den communitys zu
finden das ist eine grundvoraussetzung
für eine gute
zusammenarbeit muss man sagen ein gutes
zusammenwirken so schmidt was uns alle
ein stück weit schockiert hat ist wie
oft schusswaffen eingesetzt werden
offenbar im wer denkt man denkt das so
waffen in deutschland schusswaffen die
gibt es eigentlich nicht und dann guckt
man sich polizeimeldungen aus dem
wedding an und dann wird da gefühlt jede
woche geschossen woran liegt das
bekommen die waffen her und wir kommen
diese täter an die waffen ja die
realität scheint tatsächlich ein anderer
zu sein als das was man annehmen möchte
wenn wir hier sehen kriminelle die in
kriminellen milieus agieren in clans
agieren wie hier im sachverhalt in der
müllerstraße zum beispiel gesehen dass
es relativ einfach in diesen netzwerken
waffen zu beschaffen und die zu erlangen
das erschreckende ist dass mittlerweile
auch in anderen lebenssachverhalte
polizistinnen und polizisten immer
häufiger mit waffen konfrontiert werden
und das ist mittlerweile so einfach auf
einem illegalen markt auch im ausland
wie die jüngsten ereignisse zeigen oder
auch im darknet das ja jeglichen service
bietet waffen einfach zu kaufen frau
schmid und hermann es doch danke dass
sie heute bei uns waren und danke für
ihre expertise und
im fall des ermordeten im suv in berlin
im wedding der ermittelt die polizei
weiter und deshalb fragen die ermittler
haben sie am 13 januar 2022 zwischen
18.30 und 19.30 etwas auffälliges in der
kühnemann straße in berlin beobachtet
hinweise an das lka berlin unter 030 46
64 91 18 88